we are terrified by the violence of the
russia aggression against civilian
people in ukraine
and there are also disturbing reports
about the use of sexual violence as a
weapon of war by the russian troops
russia continues to target fields and
food stocks
everybody have seen the images
of
wheat fields being burned
they continue blocking
the experts from ukraine
they are responsible for the hunger in
the world
the war will continue
we will continue supporting
and that's why i have proposed the next
tranche
of the european peace facility
allocating 500 millions more
it has been a political agreement on
support in this proposal
and
the decision will be taken
on the next days but today the ministers
agreed on that
am sure putin's counting on the
democratic fatigue
i'm sure
he believes that democracies are
weak
and
the news
hide the news and
look no
european societies cannot afford fatigue
the european societies
and european union member states
governments have to continue
standing
behind the decision they have taken
they took the decisions on restrictive
measures on the russian economy
and they have to stick to it